of course I want to build everywhere of
course I can't be that arrogant I can't
it is it you know it will only want to
go to the World Cup but now after what
I'm doing they want to win the World Cup
for me as a footballer is something
different see myself anywhere in a
street the people I think the first time
for them to see an Egyptian famous like
that I want them to view me in the page
like is dangerous dangerous in any
moment he might I saw some out of him
from Hamid Ali dizzy and I'm very happy
to be partnered with him enjoying the
project was I was one of the greatest
athletes in the world it only makes
sense to try to put his face and in one
of the most prominent spaces on the
planet Times Square
first thing I noticed when I looked at
most of his face was his hair you know
his beard
my first thought was how can I highlight
and put a lot of texture in his hair
we're going to basically take Egyptian
patterns and colors and use that as a
map of his hair but also wanted to show
what he's celebrated for so there's a
lot of shots in his hair playing soccer
he just felt right to try to make him
larger-than-life it's a canvas that's 70
by 40 feet large when you walk around
Times Square the beauty of it as you're
walking past so many different people so
many different nationalities different
origins so many people celebrate his
power on the field but also what he
represents off the field
I always remember myself where I came
from I don't think there is any reason
for anyone to not be hungry so a lot of
them looking down is this this way of
being humble but yet he's large he could
just look over everyone but yet he's
still focusing on the people which I
think poetically is a lot about his
statue has a world actually representing
his country I would be very proud to see
my mirror in Time Square this is the
perfect space for what he represents I
think that's powerful